ya tenemos un vídeo de repaso del adn te
recomiendo que lo veas primero pero lo
que quiero que hagamos en este vídeo es
ver al adn pero más a fondo
vamos a hablar acerca de la estructura
molecular del adn y vamos a empezar
recordando el nombre completo de adn ok
adn es la abreviación de ácido
desoxirribonucleico y voy a escribir
cada parte distinta de ese nombre con un
color diferente la a viene de ácido y
luego tenemos desoxirribonucleico ácido
desoxirribonucleico y ahora sí vamos a
fijarnos en esta molécula de aquí que es
el ácido desoxirribonucleico y vamos a
ver a qué corresponden cada una de las
partes de este nombre rey adn es ácido
desoxirribonucléico
aparte de nucleico proviene del hecho de
que podemos encontrar al adn en el
núcleo de las células eucariotas la
parte de ácido vamos a hablar de eso en
unos cuantos segundos pero primero
quiero decir que cada molécula de adn
está compuesta por unas cosas a las que
les llamamos nucleótidos cada cadena de
adn está compuesta por nucleótidos y
como se ven los nucleótidos bueno pues
aquí dibujé dos hebras de adn hice un
muy buen acercamiento a dos hebras de
adn esto de aquí es como la columna
vertebral de una de las hebras de adn o
también podríamos decir que es como uno
de los lados de una escalera de mano y
esto de aquí es el otro lado de la
escalera de mano mientras que éstos son
los peldaños cada uno de estos puentes y
vamos a hablar acerca de cuáles son
estas moléculas en unos cuantos minutos
pero estos son como los peldaños de la
escalera ahora un nucleótido déjame se
paró por aquí un nucleótido un
nucleótido es esto que estoy circulando
lo que hay todo esto de aquí es lo que
consideramos un nucleótido ese es un
nucleótido y está conectado a este otro
nucleótido esto que estoy circulando
ahora es un nucleótido y de este lado
derecho también tenemos un nucleótido a
no equivoque más bien es de esta otra
forma y luego justo debajo tenemos otro
nucleótido así es que aquí dibujados
tenemos cuatro nucleótidos estos dos
están del lado izquierdo de la escalera
y estos dos están del lado derecho de la
escalera y ahora sí vamos a pensar en
las diferentes partes de cada nucleótido
seguramente de las primeras cosas que te
saltan a la vista es que los nucleótidos
tienen este grupo fosfato por aquí y
bueno este otro nucleótido también tiene
este grupo fosfato y por aquí hay otro
grupo fosfato y otro también
cada uno de estos nucleótidos tiene su
propio grupo fosfato lo que hay aquí
tenemos un grupo fosfato por acá y otro
grupo fosfato y de hecho son los grupos
fosfato los que hacen que el adn y los
ácidos nucleicos sean ácidos y aquí tú
puedes llegar y decir me oye espera un
momento aquí tú dibujaste a los grupos
fosfato con un signo menos y cualquier
molécula con una carga negativa atrae
protones los absorbe como puede ser que
me estás diciendo que este grupo fosfato
con el signo menos es un ácido esto más
bien se ve como una base
a la razón por la que dibujamos este
signo menos en las moléculas de adn es
porque es tan ácido que si la ponemos en
una solución neutra va a perder a sus
hidrógenos y de hecho si quisiéramos ser
muy formales la molécula de adn tendría
a este oxígeno protón ado nay de esta
forma al verde gemelo dibujo mejor
formalmente nos deshacemos de la carga
negativa y este oxígeno está enlazado
con un hidrógeno ahora este oxígeno
realmente se quiere quedar con estos
electrones el oxígeno si puede quedarse
con esos electrones y entonces este
protón de aquí se va con alguna molécula
de agua o algo así ok estamos soltando
al protón y por eso es que decimos que
es un ácido si el adn no estuviera en
una solución neutra tendría a todos sus
hidrógenos pero como es muy ácido en el
momento en el que lo ponemos en una
solución
a todos estos hidrógenos si es que son
estos grupos fosfatos los que hacen que
el adn sea un ácido que entiendo
perfectamente que sea un poco confuso
porque casi siempre que veas dibujada
una molécula de adn la vas a ver con
estas cargas negativas pero eso es
porque ya perdieron a sus hidrógenos en
efecto estamos dibujando la base con
jugada pero es de aquí de donde proviene
la parte de ácido porque empieza a
protón ado al menos en su forma de ácido
y después pierde a todos estos
hidrógenos nuclear y de ahí es de donde
saca el nombre de ácido ahora la
siguiente cosa que seguramente vas a
notar en estos nucleótidos es este grupo
de aquí tenemos aquí este ciclo este
anillo y se parece muchísimo a los
azúcares y bueno eso pasa porque es un
azúcar
este azúcar es un azúcar de 5 carbonos
lo tengo dibujado aquí en su forma de
cadena lineal y se llama ribosa ribosa y
lo tenemos aquí en su forma de cadena
lineal pero como la mayoría de los
azúcares también lo podemos tener en su
forma cíclica de hecho puede tomar
muchas formas cíclicas diferentes pero
la que es más comúnmente descrita es la
que tenemos por aquí abajo
claro que para describirla bien tenemos
que ponerle números a estos carbonos
sobre todo porque el número de los
carbonos es súper importante cuando
estamos hablando de adn y siempre
empezamos con el carbono del grupo
carbón y lo este carbono es el carbono 1
prima
y así nos seguimos este es el 2 prima 3
4 prima y 5 prima y para que se forme la
ribosa cíclica el oxígeno del carbono 4
primero utiliza uno de sus dos pares de
electrones libres
y tenemos aquí un par de electrones
libres y el otro par de electrones
libres y usa uno de estos dos pares de
electrones libres para formar un enlace
con el carbono uno prima y de esa forma
toda la molécula se dobla y se forma de
esta estructura también por eso lo
dibujé de esta forma porque realmente se
dobla y entonces cuando se forma un
enlace entre este oxígeno y este carbono
el carbono puede soltar uno de estos
enlaces con el oxígeno y ahora el
oxígeno puede usar esos electrones para
ir y encontrar algún protón por ahí ok
para hacer un enlace con un hidrógeno y
una vez que pasa todo esto nos
encontramos de esta forma y sólo para
que quede más claro todo este de aquí es
el carbono 1 prima
2 prima 3 prima 4 prima y 5 prima
y aquí donde tenemos el doble enlace en
este grupo carbón hilo el carbono 1
prima suelta uno de estos enlaces dobles
y de esa forma el oxígeno puede formar
un enlace con algún protón de hidrógeno
ok el carbono uno prima lo encontramos
por aquí antes tenía un doble enlace con
el oxígeno pero lo soltó y ahora el
oxígeno tiene un enlace con este
hidrógeno de aquí así es que este protón
de hidrógeno es este de acá y por otro
lado este enlace verde que dibujamos por
aquí entre el carbono 4 primer o bueno
más bien entre el oxígeno que está
enlazado con el carbono 4 prima y ahora
si el carbono 1 prima
este enlace que tenemos por aquí este
oxígeno es este oxígeno que tenemos aquí
y observa este oxígeno está enlazado al
carbono 4 primero como a crear pero
ahora también está enlazado al carbono 1
prima y antes también estaba enlazado
con un hidrógeno pero fácilmente podemos
perder a este protón de hidrógeno con
alguna molécula de agua que pase por
allí se lleve a este protón y se
convierta en una molécula de idron yo y
ahora en total
aquí estamos tomando un protón de
hidrógeno de la solución y aquí estamos
regresando un protón de hidrógeno a la
solución así es que no le estamos ni
quitando ni agregando nada a la solución
y así es como formamos la estructura
cíclica de la ribosa y esta estructura
se parece muchísimo a estas estructuras
que tenemos aquí en las moléculas de adn
y bueno de hecho podemos encontrar
exactamente esta estructura en las
moléculas de a
en los ácidos ribonucleicos ahora porque
no son exactamente iguales bueno pues
aquí es donde nos podemos preguntar por
qué tenemos el prefijo de shock si en el
ácido desoxirribonucleico a que nos
estaremos refiriendo cuando decimos
desoxirribonucleico podemos empezar por
aquí con una molécula de ribosa y si
llegáramos a perder alguno de estos
oxígenos entonces tendríamos una
desoxirribonucleico átomos de los cuales
cuatro son carbonos y tienen una
estructura muy parecida a lo que tenemos
por acá
aunque los hidrógenos y carbonos están
todos aquí implícitamente eso sí lo
hemos visto un montón de veces en cada
uno de estos vértices donde se juntan
dos líneas dos enlaces tenemos un
carbono y además también cuando tenemos
por ejemplo un vértice que se acabe en
un puntito ahí también tenemos un carbón
y bueno los hidrógenos también están ahí
implícitamente ahora si nos ponemos a
comparar estas dos moléculas podemos ver
por aquí que este tiene un grupo o h en
este carbono mientras que este carbono
de aquí en lugar de tener ese grupo o h
implícitamente sólo tiene este hidrógeno
bueno de hecho ok aquí este carbono
tiene este otro hidrógeno también y este
carbono tiene este otro hidrógeno
también pero este carbono ya no tiene un
grupo o h por acá
así es que perdió un oxígeno y por lo
tanto es una de sox y arribos a ok la
desoxirribonucleico
no tiene el oxígeno que está enlazado
con el carbono 2 prima así es que si
tenemos una molécula de estas y nos
deshacemos del oxígeno del carbono 2
primero obtenemos una
esta es una de sox y rebosa
desoxirribonucleico estas partes de aquí
a las que les llamamos las bases
nitrogenadas great esta es una base
nitrogenada base nitrogenada y hay
varios tipos de bases nitrogenadas
aunque hay aquí también tenemos otra
base de nitrógeno de distinta y esta de
aquí también es otra base de nitrógeno
de distinta y observa esta base nada más
tiene un anillo esta también tiene
únicamente un anillo pero esta otra base
nitrogenada ahora tiene dos anillos y
esta otra de aquí también tiene dos
anillos y bueno tenemos diferentes
nombres para cada una de estas bases
nitrogenadas a la categorización de
estas bases nitrogenadas que tienen
los anillos les llamamos purinas así es
que de estas bases nitrogenadas si hay
una que tiene dos anillos les llamamos
purinas pero si tienen únicamente un
anillo como en estas dos bases un anillo
decimos que son pir y medinas
líneas
y ahora en particular estas dos bases
estas 2 purinas la de aquí arriba se
llama adenina y bueno ya hemos visto
cómo se unen por pares en el vídeo de
introducción del adn pero bueno esta
base de aquí es la adenina
a de nivel y por acá tenemos la guanina
y luego por aquí tenemos estas dos bases
nitrogenadas que tienen un solo anillo y
por lo tanto son piri midi nash ahora la
base piri medina de aquí arriba es la
timina timina si estamos hablando del
adn porque si estuviéramos hablando de
la rn tendríamos que hablar del brasil
pero no estamos hablando del adn y
entonces es la timina y finalmente esta
base nitrogenada de aquí es la citosina
de tocina y también podemos ponernos a
ver cómo se atraen la timina se enlaza
con la adenina y la citosina se enlaza
con la guanina ahora como sucede en esos
enlaces como están formando los peldaños
de esta escalera de adn como se están
enlazando la forma en la que estas bases
nitrogenadas forman los peldaños de la
dm
la forma en la que se atraen mutuamente
es a través de los famosos puentes de
hidrógeno y estos funcionan porque el
nitrógeno es un átomo muy electro
negativo y entonces al estar enlazados
con hidrógenos van a tener una carga
parcial negativa y cada uno de esos
hidrógenos va a tener una carga parcial
positiva y por otro lado el oxígeno como
hemos dicho siempre el oxígeno también
es muy electro negativo y por lo tanto
también tiene una carga parcial negativa
y entonces el oxígeno con su carga
parcial negativa va a sentirse muy
atraído por la carga parcial positiva
del hidrógeno y así es como se forma el
puente de hidrógeno y lo mismo va a
pasar con este hidrógeno de aquí
ok porque este hidrógeno está enlazado
con un nitrógeno que es muy electro
negativo y entonces está abrazando mucho
a los electrones de este enlace por lo
que el hidrógeno tiene una carga parcial
positiva
este nitrógeno de aquí también tiene una
carga parcial negativa porque es muy
electrón negativo y está abrazando muy
fuertemente a todos los electrones de
estos enlaces entonces hay una fuerte
atracción entre este hidrógeno y este
nitrógeno formándose un puente de
hidrógeno y lo mismo sucede más abajo
por aquí tenemos un hidrógeno cuyos
electrones están siendo muy abrazados
por este nitrógeno entonces el hidrógeno
tiene una carga parcial positiva y
también tenemos aquí un oxígeno con una
carga parcial negativa entonces se van a
sentir muy atraídos mutuamente lo mismo
sucede entre este nitrógeno y este
hidrógeno y también lo mismo sucede
entre este oxígeno y este hidrógeno y es
por eso que siempre se juntan la
citosina y la guanina y la timina y la
adenina y también hablamos un poquito de
eso en el vídeo de introducción al adn